where are we going to get the wealth to
build the types of businesses that we
want and the answer is going to have to
be cooperative economics
there's a lot of different versions of
cooperativism what I'm talking about
today is worker ownership right now
today in South Bronx is the country's
largest worker-owned company and it was
founded by black and latinx home care
workers who are now able to pay
themselves living wages they have
full-time hours they have benefits and a
pension through their membership as a
unit of SEIU and these women owners now
receive a dividend back on their
ownership every year that the company
has been profitable which has been most
years they don't have any big investors
they don't have fat cat CEOs or absentee
owners taking the profit out of the
company
they each pay in about a thousand
dollars over time in order to gain
ownership and now they own their job I'm
so inspired by by what they're doing
because it really represents an
alternative to the type of economy we
have now which exploits all of us